Okay, Charles, so what do you, what do you think about this?
>> Wait, how old are my children?
>> Let's say what their adult height is going to be.
>> I would expect them to be a little bit smaller than me.
>> A little bit smaller than you?
>> Mm-hmm.
>> So, so their, the average height, their
average height of your children, you would you say
it would be like an average height person?
Or like your height or sort of in between?
>> In between.
>> In between. All right. So it
turns out that if you actually do this, you measure people's
heights and you measure the heights of their children, that that
is in fact what you tend to see. That very, very
tall people, like you tend to have taller than average children.
But the height is between. It actually regresses to the mean.
And here we really do mean regresses in the sense of
going back to this kind of more primitive state that, if
you think about average height people, as being like your ancestors,
then, you know, you as a, as a very tall
person tend to have kids that that tend regress back
toward that average value that sort of, more older, more
ancient value. So does that that make some sense to you?
>> That makes some sense. But one comment and
one question. Comment, that is awesome because I've always actually
wondered what regresses to the mean actually means. The second,
what prevents us from all being the same height then?
>> Yes, so what,
what seems to be happening is that there's a kind of a noisy process and some
people turn out to be taller, but then
the, then the next generation there's a little
bit of a history effect in people stay
taller, but it tends to drift back towards
the mean. So it's, so it's, it's sort of like a random walk, to some extent.
>> Oh, that actually kind of makes sense.